what do you think is
uh the meaning of this whole thing so
you look at planets
they they seem to orbit stuff um
without without asking the why question
and for some reason
life emerged on earth such that it led
to big brains that
can ask the big why question do you
think there's an answer to it
um i'm not sure what the question is
like what meaning of life the meaning of
life uh
it's 42. it's 42. yeah but
you know aside from that it's um you
know
why i think the if the question you're
asking is like
why we do all this right
yeah it's part of the human condition
right human beings are fundamentally
i feel like non like sort of stochastic
and fundamentally interested in in
kind of expanding our own understanding
of the world
around us and creating stuff to enable
that understanding
so we're like stochastic fundamentally
so like there's
just a bunch of randomness that really
doesn't seem like it has a good
explanation
and yet there's a kind of direction to
our being that we just keep wanting to
create and to understand
that's right i've met people that are
you know that claim to be anti-science
right um and yet
in their anti-science you know
discussion
like well like if you're so you know
scientific then how why don't you
explain to me how
i don't know this works and like it
always there's that fundamental
speed of curiosity and interest that is
common to
to all of us that is absolutely what
makes us
human right and and i
i'm in a privileged position of being
able to you know
to have that be my my job right
i think as uh you know as time
evolves forward you know and the kind of
economy changes i mean we're already
starting to see
you know shift towards that type of you
know
creative uh you know enterprise as being
as emerging as taking over a bigger and
bigger chunk of the
sector it's not yet i think the dominant
uh portion of the by any account but if
we compare this
to like you know sometime when
the dominant thing you would do would be
to
you know go to a factory and do the same
exact thing
right i think you know there's a tide
there
and things are sort of headed in that
direction yeah life's becoming more and
more fun
i can't wait uh honestly what i can't
wait to just
chill just just chill terminal point of
this
chill and wait for those kuiper belt
objects to complete one orbit
you